berceau de la renaissance française le
château d'amboise est un des joyaux les
plus connus du val de loire pourtant de
nombreuses surprises peuvent encore nous
y attendre surtout quand c'est son
passionnant directeur qui mène la visite
visiter le château d'amboise c'est
prendre de la hauteur sur la vallée la
loire
découvrir la grande histoire de france
serwa ces grands hommes et pour en
déceler toutes les singularités
mieux vaut disposer d'un guide à la
hauteur
bonjour madame
tallien c'est jean-louis sureau dirige
les lieux depuis plus de 20 ans et nous
accorde une visite de sa composition
allez on continue en français pour vous
non
alors nous nous trouvons dans un endroit
à peu original en fait c'est une de ces
tours dax est donc au château d'amboise
qui sont construites en fait comme des
parkings moderne c'est-à-dire une grande
piste qui fait cinq boucles et qui
permet d'accéder depuis la ville au
niveau des terrasses du château
à celui qui sait bien regarder cette
bâtisse royal dévoile de nombreuses
bizarreries mais le château d'amboise
insolite c'est aussi celui que le
visiteur ne voit pas ces souterrains et
sa chaudière installée fin 19e et juste
à côté la tour d'accès nord qui fut le
témoin d'un passé peu connues est plus
obscur celui des prisonniers des rois de
france
donc là on a vraiment un dessin qui
illustre parfaitement donc l'ennui que
pouvait avoir vous pouvez prouver des
prisonniers et donc qu'ils ont réalisé
un damier ont réalisé sur le mur de la
même façon que l'on voit les traces ici
des bâtons en deçà comme le nombre de
jours de détention
évidemment le temps est long et on
compte les jours
finalement c'est peut-être ça le côté
insolite d'amboise cette histoire faite
de contrastes d'anecdotes et de
multiples histoires personnelles sans
compter sont imprenables vue sur la
loire dont même les prisonniers pourrait
profiter